ahora que tenemos la fórmula del
desplazamiento en función de la
velocidad inicial y del tiempo vamos a
poder graficar el desplazamiento la
aceleración y la velocidad en función
del tiempo para que comprendamos
perfectamente qué es lo que sucede con
la pelota al ir subiendo y a ir bajando
ya tenemos entonces la fórmula del
desplazamiento y también tenemos la
fórmula de la velocidad final que es
esta fórmula
y bueno tenemos que nuestra aceleración
de la gravedad es menos 9.8 metros sobre
segundo al cuadrado es negativa porque
nuestra convención es que todo lo que va
a dirección hacia abajo es negativo
todas las cantidades que tienen cada
todo el vector que tiene que va hacia
arriba va a ser una cantidad positiva y
ahora vamos a proceder a gráficas
entonces vamos a hacer espacio aquí
vamos a hacer primero nuestra gráfica
del desplazamiento
con respecto al tiempo
entonces tengo mi eje
del cambio en el tiempo
tengo mi eje del desplazamiento
y voy a graduar
y aquí vamos a tener
5 10 15
metros metros aquí vamos a poner es la
unidad aquí son metros aquí en el tiempo
son segundos y aquí tenemos
15 20 y aquí en el tiempo tenemos 1 2 3
4 y esta es mi gráfica
del
desplazamiento
disculpen la letra que no me sale tan
bonita aquí usando este aparato pero
bueno espero que se entienda ahora voy a
poner a escribir los ejes de la
velocidad contra el tiempo esta es
diferente porque aquí voy tengo valores
positivos y negativos
y tengo aquí el eje del cambio del
tiempo esto es mi velocidad
valores positivos y negativos el tiempo
sigue siendo 4 segundos 1 2 3 4
4 y de la velocidad voy a tener la
velocidad se mide en metros sobre
segundo voy a tener aquí
10 metros sobre segundo aquí arriba
20 metros sobre segundo y aquí voy a
tener menos 10 metros sobre segundo y
aquí menos 20 metros sobre segundo voy a
hacer otra tabla más que es mi tabla de
la aceleración esta es muy sencillita
tengo mi eje que puede ser aceleración
positiva o negativa tengo mi eje del
tiempo antes de que se me olvide voy a
poner la etiqueta de que esta gráfica
anterior es la de velocidad
velocidad
y esta es la del desplazamiento entonces
tengo igual pero esta es la de la
aceleración y como mi aceleración es
constante y es de menos
9.8 metros sobre segundo
yo tengo aquí
esta es mi aceleración
metros sobre segundo al cuadrado es la
unidad
y aquí tengo mi marca de menos 10 y el
9.8 más o menos está por aquí y como es
aceleración constante no importa el
cambio del tiempo
voy a tener la misma aceleración
entonces así queda mi gráfica de la
aceleración
y aparte voy a hacer una pequeña tabla
vamos a ponerla de un color azul bonito
y esta tabla voy a gráficas
más o menos así
no tengo impulso hoy ustedes disculpen
pero trataré de hacerlo lo más derechito
posible esta queda mejor voy a tener los
valores aquí de él
desplazamiento
perdón mi primer valor va a ser el
cambio en el tiempo
en la siguiente columna voy a tener mi
velocidad final o la velocidad en este
tiempo
y en esta otra columna voy a tener ahora
sin mi desplazamiento
entonces comienzo en el tiempo cero me
encuentro aquí en este punto en todas
las las gráficas
bueno tengo
cuando tengo el tiempo cero revisando
nuestras fórmulas de la velocidad
la velocidad final es igual a la
velocidad inicial más la aceleración por
el cambio en el tiempo
cuando tengo mi tiempo
igual a cero
este término es igual a 0 por lo que
multiplicado por cualquier cosa va a ser
igual a 0 y aquí voy a tener el valor de
la velocidad inicial
entonces
mi velocidad final o me iba velocidad en
el momento del tiempo igual a cero va a
ser igual a mi velocidad inicial y mi
velocidad inicial la tenemos aquí
definida como 19.6 metros sobre segundo
entonces mi velocidad final va a ser
igual a
19.6 metros sobre segundo si yo gráfico
aquí mi velocidad en el tiempo cero es
mi velocidad inicial 19.6 aquí un
poquito abajo del 20 aquí va a estar y
si quiero conocer mi desplazamiento
en el tiempo cero el desplazamiento es
igual a la velocidad inicial por el
cambio de tiempo el cambio de tiempo
aquí es cero entonces ese término es
igual a cero
y aquí también tengo mi desvían cambiar
el tiempo que es 0 eso también se vuelve
0 por lo que mi desplazamiento
va a ser cero no me voy a estar moviendo
aquí en mi gráfica mi desplazamiento en
el tiempo cero va a ser ser voy a estar
aquí
ahora entonces vamos a poner estos
valores en la gráfica para el tiempo
cero mi velocidad inicial va a ser
bueno mi velocidad final mi velocidad en
este momento va a ser de 19.6 y el
desplazamiento va a ser igual a cero
ahora qué pasa cuando estoy en el primer
segundo
entonces me cambia el tiempo es igual a
un segundo cuál va a ser mi velocidad
final mi velocidad final va a ser igual
en este caso
a la velocidad inicial
más la aceleración por el cambio en el
tiempo en este caso este valor es 1 por
lo que en la aceleración multiplicada
por 1 que da igual la aceleración y esto
va a ser igual a mi velocidad inicial
que son
19.6
metros sobre segundo más
mi aceleración
qué es
la aceleración es menos
recordamos que la aceleración es va
hacia abajo y negativa por la convención
entonces menos
9.8
metros sobre segundo y si hacemos esta
resta pues va a quedar igual a
19.6 menos 9.8 queda igual a 9.8 metros
sobre segundo esta es mi velocidad
cuando tengo un segundo
9.8 en la gráfica en este segundo 9.8 va
quedando más o menos por acá voy uniendo
los valores de este punto a este punto
para que veamos más claro que está
pasando y ahora calculemos el
desplazamiento entonces el
desplazamiento con esta fórmula es mi
velocidad inicial por el cambio en el
tiempo que es un segundo entonces me
queda mi velocidad inicial mi velocidad
inicial es d
19.6
metros sobre segundo
más la mitad de la aceleración por la
cambio del tiempo al cuadrado el
cuadrado de 1 sigue siendo 1 por lo que
este valor es la mitad de la aceleración
entonces tenemos que la aceleración
que es negativa va a ser igual a menos
la mitad de
9.8 esto es igual a 9.8 entre 2
los usamos nuestra calculadora
ahorita después de sacar mi calculadora
y entonces tenemos el
9.8 entre 2
4.9
4.9 entonces esto nos va a quedar
si yo restó 4.9 a
19.6
19 puntos 6 menos
y 4.9
me queda
14.7 el desplazamiento
14.7 esos metros si observamos de esta
fórmula vemos que la velocidad de cerca
de metros sobre segundo lo multiplicamos
por el tiempo en segundos por lo que los
segundos se anulan y nada más quedan los
metros y eso se suma a lo que es la
aceleración unidades metros sobre
segundo al cuadrado multiplicado por un
tiempo en segundos al cuadrado y esos
segundos al cuadrado se anulan y nos
quedan solo metros de manera que este
resultado está en métodos y los
dibujamos en nuestra gráfica tenemos
14.7 metros en el primer segundo más o
menos por acá
estará el segundo punto en el
desplazamiento entonces aquí en nuestro
dólares
14.7 metros que pasa en el segundo
segundo
cambio en el tiempo igual a 2 nuestra
velocidad en este momento
es igual
aquí está en esta fórmula la velocidad
inicial que está siempre queda es 19.6
metros sobre segundo
esto va a estar multiplicado por la
aceleración por el tiempo en este caso
el tiempo son 2 entonces está menos 9.8
va a estar multiplicado por 2 y 9.8 por
2 es 19 puntos 6
entonces esto se resta y nuestra
velocidad en este momento va a ser igual
a cero aquí en nuestro segundo 2 la
velocidad es cero
aquí lo graficó esto es 0 y para
calcular nuestro desplazamiento
tenemos que
nuestra velocidad inicial multiplicada
por el tiempo de velocidad inicial por 2
nuestra velocidad inicial son 19
19.6 por 2 segundos aquí pongo las
unidades metros sobre segundo 2 segundos
esto se anulan menos
nuestra aceleración de la gravedad
gravedad
bueno menos un medio óvalo nuestra
celebración de la gravedad es de entre 2
que es menos
4.9
multiplicado por el cambio del tiempo al
cuadrado 2 al cuadrado 2 por 2 4 x 4 y
aquí nuestro desplazamiento
vamos a usar la calculadora
para hacer esto entonces es
19.6
por 2
menos
4.9 por 4
y esto es igual a
19.6
entonces el desplazamiento 19 puntos 6
en el segundo 2 llega más o menos casi
el 20 por acá
19.6 que pasa en el minuto hoy perdón en
el segundo tres del tate igual a tres
la velocidad final
igual a casa así que ya vemos estamos a
miles ya dos con los cálculos 19 puntos
6 metros sobre segundo menos
ahora es
la aceleración por el cambio del tiempo
el cambio de tiempo estrés
entonces es menos 9.8
por 3
y esto va a ser igual
menos
y
9.8
ahora nuestra velocidad está siendo
negativa menos 9.8 en el tiempo 3 el
desplazamiento
igual a
en nuestra velocidad inicial
19.6
multiplicada por el tiempo que en este
caso son 3
menos
4.9 por 3 al cuadrado 3 por 3 viene
siendo 9 vamos a hacer entonces de nuevo
nuestra calculadora
19.6
por 3
y esto lo voy a restar
4.9 por 9
y esto me da igual
menos
14 puntos 7 menos 14 puntos 7 y en la
gráfica viene siendo
14.7
es este valor pero ahora está en sentido
contrario ahorita era positivo en esta
parte porque iba subiendo el menos me
indica que va las direcciones hacia
abajo por eso es que esta gráfica bueno
va aquí es el menos no es que se vaya
abajo o que luego tengamos un
desplazamiento negativo como tal sino
simplemente va en un sentido contrario y
aquí es cuando vemos la importancia de
los vectores de indicar la dirección del
vector con los sentidos positivos o
negativos
y finalmente nuestro último tiempo para
calcular
cuando tenemos cuatro segundos cambian
el tiempo igual a cuatro velocidad final
velocidad final
igual la velocidad inicial
19.6
metros sobre segundo menos
9.8 por 4 y esto va a ser igual
-
19.6
entonces que iba a ser menos
19.6 de la misma manera la dirección es
hacia abajo
aquí no gráfica en la velocidad el valor
de menos 9.8 en el tiempo 3 son el
segundo 3 va a ser aquí más o menos y en
el tiempo 4 su velocidad va a ser más o
menos por acá entonces uniendo estas
no quedó muy derecho pero se entiende
que esto es una línea recta y ahora para
encontrar el desplazamiento
rápidamente
19 puntos 6
por el tiempo que es 4
-
4.9 por
4 al cuadrado 4 por 4 16
y para este
de nuevo usamos nuestra calculadora
19 puntos 6
por 4
menos
4.9 por
y nos queda desplazamiento igual a cero
aquí de este punto en el tiempo 4 llega
de nuevo a 0 la gráfica aquí como queda
pues va a quedar
vamos a agarrar otros colores
[Música]
llega aquí va por acá va subiendo
lo puedo hacer mejor
más o menos por aquí
sube llega el punto máximo y empieza a
bajar
en el llega al suelo en el momento 4
oria no tiene el desplazamiento el
desplazamiento 0 en este tiempo
entonces bueno qué es lo que está
pasando con la con la pelota bueno
tenemos una aceleración o una
desaceleración constante en esta
velocidad por este sentido tenemos una
debido a esta aceleración negativa esta
tenemos una pendiente de menos 9.8 si
usará música le sacáramos la derivada de
ésta
curva la pendiente de esta curva y aquí
si yo estoy
si yo quisiera gráficas en esta misma
gráfica del desplazamiento expresar los
vectores de velocidad en esta misma que
tendría bueno en el tiempo cero mi
velocidad o la magnitud de este vector
era 19.6 entonces la velocidad en este
momento en el cero cuando la lancé la
pelota al aire más o menos llegó hasta
acá este es mi vector velocidad
en el en el primer segundo la magnitud
es casi la mitad 9 punt hecho es la
mitad 9.8 entonces más o menos el vector
digo así para lo que es el segundo el
segundo número 2
el desplazamiento pero la velocidad es
cero ya no tenemos aquí velocidad y en
el tercer segundo la velocidad la
tenemos pero en sentido negativo en
sentido hacia abajo esta magnitud y para
el minuto 4 la velocidad la magnitud es
la misma con la que iba hacia arriba
pero ahora hacia abajo justo antes de
dar contra el suelo esta es la velocidad
que tiene la
pelota que lanzamos al aire
y si queremos graficar la acelera la
aceleración que la aceleración es
constante la voy a ocupar con un color
naranja para que se distinga la
aceleración es negativa y es de menos
9.8 entonces en este punto cero la la
atracción de la gravedad o la
aceleración de la gravedad sigue siendo
negativa es constante en todo momento va
a estar en el primer segundo esta
aceleración negativa va a estar hacia
acá en el tercer segundo va a estar la
es la misma magnitud de todos estos
vectores en este segundo pues va a estar
también aquí
y en el último segundo ya cuando cae la
magnitud de la aceleración como vector
va a estar aquí espero que esto les
ayuda a comprender qué es lo que sucede
cuando lanzamos un proyectil al aire